what is consciousness
bro so you're actually using techniques
i mean even putting psychiatry aside
just looking
at optogenetics
you're trying to understand some of
these deep aspects of the human mind
and maybe this is a good time to return
to a question you mentioned
you might have an opinion on if there's
such a thing as a theory of everything
for the human mind
because surely answering of what is
consciousness is as
well that's not sure
but it seems like it's a fundamental
part of the human
experience in the human mind and solving
that question
will result in solving
the bigger thing about the human mind
the flip side could be consciousness
it's just the few neurons that are
generating some useful thing that make
us it's like uh
the the sense of self that you talked
about in the in the mice
maybe it's a subset of those cells that
are just creating a richer sense of self
and that's it
so
this is a great question
all neuroscientists think about this and
a lot of non-neuroscientists too it's
it's such a
it's the reason a lot of people came to
the study of the brain is to think about
consciousness and not just
being awake or alert but really
what's sometimes called the hard problem
of consciousness which is what is that
nature of that inner subjective sense we
have not just information processing
but feeling something about the
information that what is that inner
state of subjectivity physically what is
it
and that's called the hard problem of
consciousness and
it's not an extremely well-defined
question everybody has sort of a sense
of what it means but
it's such a hard problem because you run
into paradoxes quite quickly the more
you think about it and that
is exciting also because it makes us
think actually there's some fundamental
there's a big thing that we're missing
the brain is not just a collection of
little tricks there is a big
big concept so that's your sense of
because like a flip side could be with
optogenetics you can
there's an engineering question can you
turn consciousness on and off like a
light switch okay so here here's where
exactly consciousness frames the problem
extremely well and it frames it the
following way so i told you earlier that
we can
stimulate 20 or 25 cells in
the visual cortex of a mouse and we can
make it
behave and we can make its brain act as
if it's seeing something that isn't
there we have that level of control now
we can pick out 25 neurons play an
activity
in both behavior and in the brain it's
as if it's seeing something specific
okay
now let's do a thought experiment you
know a good duncan experiment and let's
play this out
let's say we could do the same thing for
every single neuron in the brain of a
human being let's say we had total
control
and i could do something like i could
show you
a rich deep color red and you could look
at it and you would be aware that it's
red but also you might have some
feelings about it some something would
be stirred in you some subjective sense
as you looked at that rich color red
and then
i would take away
the visual stimulus and i would in this
thought experiment i would
using some hyperoptogenetics i would
play in
exactly the same pattern of activity in
every cell in your brain
for as long as it was needed whatever 15
seconds something like that that exactly
matched
what was going on when you were feeling
that inner subjective sense
okay so in that thought experiment a
question for you is would you
be feeling that same inner subjective
sense stimulus is gone every neuron's
doing the same thing because i'm
controlling it
there's a philosophical question there
i'm if if you ask me specifically i
would say yes
okay good most people would say that
because it's hard to say no right it's
very hard to say if every cell in your
brain is doing what it was doing
what what else could be different how
could well most normal people would say
yes
of course philosophers would then
start saying no they're they're the ones
that say
um i'm i'm going to sort of to parallel
and sorry if it's a bit of an
interruption but if there's you know if
there's a robot that's conscious in
front of you
if it appears conscious
then
it's conscious like to me
uh of course philosophers again speak up
and say well no how do you know it's
conscious well
how do you know anything is conscious
and sort of as normal humans
we tend to um
lean on the experience versus some kind
of
philosophical concept
so the great thing about the the what
you just said the the turing test is
it's very practical
if it acts conscious it is conscious
but i think that's limiting i like the
the thought experiment i think it's
actually more informative and so i'm
halfway halfway to the to the conclusion
there but let's let's let's take it as
your answer was yes that's that you
would be feeling the same thing okay now
here's where it gets fun
now that every cell in your brain
is knows what it has to do in the sense
that we know it and we're providing it
your brain cells don't need to be in
your head anymore at all right
the only reason they're next to each
other the only reason they're wired
together is to affect each other to
stimulate or inhibit each other
but we don't need that anymore because
optogenetically we're providing that
activity pattern for as long as needed
we're providing the effect of the
communication they don't need to be
connected anymore
they don't even need to be in your head
i could spread your neurons
all over the continent all over the
galaxy
and i could still provide
the same stimulus pattern over 10 or 15
seconds to all those neurons and
somewhere
lex friedman would be
would have to be even though no longer
existing as a
physical object anymore would be feeling
that subjective feeling
and it's inescapable because it's
exactly the same as the previous
situation all the neurons have to be uh
spatially
like the locality constraint they have
to be spatially close to each other
uh
and you talk about light opto which is
funny because
you know light
is the fastest traveling thing that we
know of
well maybe let's not put them all over
the universe because we might get
relativistic problems then let's let's
just keep them on let's keep all your
neurons let's spread them over north
america okay and and let's let's play
them out
same pattern of activity
and right it seems absurd right there's
no way that could be true there's no way
that that that lex would be feeling that
internal sense if his neurons were
spread all over north america
and yet it's exactly the same as the
previous situation where you said sure
wow so we've got a paradox and it and
this is what makes people say paradox
though sorry
yeah yeah maybe products is the wrong
word we got a problem
we got a problem because it reveals
that there's something big
about
those that internal subjective state
that we're not explaining and we don't
really have a hope of explaining in the
near future but don't you think we would
still have that
it's just the word internal loses
meaning but don't you think we
still have that internal subjective
state
where's the
uh
if not then where the heck is the magic
coming from
okay well i just think
i think they're one one of the problems
that i think we need to let go of
is we tend to
outside of the experience of
consciousness the heart problem of
consciousness
we tend to think that we individual
humans are really special
not the subjective experience but the
entirety of it like the body
that contains the thing so the local
the the constraint of all the stuff has
to be together and it's all mine
that that's a very
i don't know if that has anything to do
with the mechanisms that are creating
this
so i and in fact one really nice way
to break through that is to
either achieve either observe or create
consciousness that spans
multiple organisms
sort of so like that say it's not
it's not an organism-dependent
phenomena that the phenomena can
that's just a peculiar way it has
evolved
on earth
but it's it's a it's a phenomena that
doesn't have anything to do with a
specific
um
biological system
all right so and we have different parts
of
our brain exist and sometimes
create
complex awarenesses
of things that involve
different
neurons that are distributed widely and
that need to communicate with each other
to form this joint representation the
state of consciousness
but indeed
why do they have to be in the same
head we don't
know why that would be the case that
they do
and so that's a
huge
unanswered question in the field is is
what is it
that binds
the activity of neurons together so they
can form a joint representation and
actually this comes back to the
dissociation experiment we talked about
before where you can your sense of self
becomes separated from your your
your body
those things that were refused in a
joint representation the same concept
unitary
are now separate
and
in late 2020 we published a paper in
nature showing how this could be
we used optogenetics to
drive this rhythm that ketamine and pcp
cause in retrospinal cortex and we got
different parts
of the brain to be out of sync and when
they were active never able to be active
at the same time never able to form
a joint representation at the same time
and so we've got a toehold into these
questions we don't have the answers but
and that mimics the dynamics of ketamine
effects exactly exactly
and you're able to find that kind of
oscillation uh
oh wow wow wow let's see if you get even
greater and greater control
with more control over individual
neurons and understanding
like if you think of certain neurons
that having some
role to play in in the sense of self you
can play like an orchestra
um that to create the certain degrees of
consciousness decreases subjectivity and
thereby
understand what is consciousness
but
by having a very complicated light
switch essentially
that and here's the here's the challenge
is
the nice thing about the the thought
experiment is it it kind of highlights
that we're going to hit a point where
we're
addressing some very very fundamental
questions what what
what allows
the activity of
two sets of neurons
to become mutually relevant to each
other
this is this is in some ways
maybe the
one of the deepest remaining questions
in neurosciences is what allows activity
patterns to become
relevant to each other
do they have to be in sync temporarily
do they need to be
is there some other
quality that we don't know about that
also needs to be present to allow cells
to to fuse together into a joint
representation
just just so i understand because it uh
it feels
close to some very very deep idea
so there's a bunch of semi-distributed
signals going on in the brain
and
you're saying there could be
something like a theory of everything if
one to exist is to understand why
how and why signals close to each other
start becoming
relevant to each other that's right
that's right as part of some very much
bigger
signal that they're producing that's
right how they coordinate essentially
um
because it's very distributed i mean
that's a kind of
within a distributed system how is order
achieved
and this is a very specific kind of
distributed system that is one of the
most intelligent that we're aware of
in the known universe
and that would maybe be something also
an understanding of the the full
conscious experience too
that this kind of coordination how does
the coordination between different
neurons that are responsible for sense
of self
how do they begin to form a big picture
that we see as a human experience
that's really really interesting so
uniting the small and i mean
that's actually literally theory of
everything re uniting the small the sort
of the theory of the neuron
um the functioning of the neuron with
the big
just the um
the functioning of the entire mind
that's right and i think keeping a toe
hold in both at the cellular level of
resolution
and the brain wide resolution will be
critical if you lose touch with either i
think you'll miss the big
insight so that's what we're trying to
do
keeping our
keeping grounded in the cellular
resolution trying to keep the the
broadest brain wide perspective
and meet in the middle
do you think you'll see it in your
lifetime a major breakthrough in that
dimension i have hope i have hope i'm
i'm uh it's very hard to predict what
will happen with with big things like
this
if we don't get there there'll be plenty
of other exciting stuff so it's okay
you